It’s the middle of the night, let’s imagine,
and we’ve been on the earth for about three
months. A lot is still very unclear. We are
profoundly helpless, barely able to move our
own head and utterly at the mercy of others.
The sources of our suffering and joy lie far
outside our understanding. Hugely powerful
needs pass through us at regular intervals
and we have no way of making sense of them
to ourselves – let alone of communicating
them reliably to others. A minute ago, we
were asleep in a dark enveloping warmth. Now
we’re awake, bereft, isolated and very uncomfortable.
There seems to be a pain somewhere in our
stomach, but the agony is more general; we
are lonely and profoundly sad. The room is
dark and there’s a mysterious set of shadows
on the wall that appear and vanish at random.
In a rising panic, we start to scream out
in the darkness. Nothing happens. We pause
to recover our breath – and then scream
even louder. Our lungs strain with the effort.
Still nothing and the darkness and loneliness
grow ever more threatening. Now true desperation
sets in; this feels like the end of everything
good and true – and we scream as if to ward
off death. At last, just when it seems we
could not go on any further, the door opens.
A warm orange light is turned on. It is a
familiar face. They smile at us, say the name
they often use around us, pick us up and put
us against their shoulder. We can hear a familiar
heart beating next to ours and a warm hand
caressing the top of our head. They gently
move us to and fro, and sing a tender, sweet
song. Our sobs start to abate, we pull a weak
smile; it feels like the vicious demons and
merciless goblins have been sent packing – and
that life could be bearable after all. Image
result for mother and child painting Soothing
is one of the kindest gestures that humans
ever perform for one another. It must lie
close to the core of love – and is what
can make the difference between a desire to
die and the capacity to endure. Awkwardly,
it tends to be very hard to soothe ourselves
unless we have first – usually in childhood
– been properly soothed by someone else.
A capacity for self-soothing is the legacy
of a history of nurture. If we have been picked
up enough times early on, and sufficiently
reassured in the midst of panic that we will
make it, then one part of the mind learns
the art and can practice it on the other – and
eventually, on people outside us too. At moments
of crisis, we find ourselves able to access
a voice that calms the waves of fear and the
blows of self-hatred: we can sort this out;
we’ll have a conversation with them; people
understand; screw them if they don’t; what
matters is you; you are good and valuable.
We have available an unflustered, resolute
response as much to the most awful events
as to routine panics. We have a faith that
we can endure, that something will show up
and that we don’t deserve the worst. Reflecting
on the art of soothing may bring into focus
just how much we are missing. We are not mysteriously
deficient, we were brought up by adults who
were themselves not soothed. We need to grow
attentive and deeply sympathetic to the missing
pieces of our psyche. It is because we didn’t
benefit from soothing that life is so much
harder than it should be; that nowadays rejection
is so bitter, social media is so frightening,
disapproval feels so fatal, ambiguity is so
unbearable, sleep feels so unearnt, holidays
are so worrying, the caresses of others feel
so alien – and so many of our days and nights
are rocked by what feel like near-death experiences.
Image result for mother and child painting
There are – one must believe – substitutes
and opportunities for catching up. We can
have recourse to music, diaries, beds, baths
but, most importantly, other people. However,
seeking out the sort of people who can soothe
us may be the hardest step. We may mistake
a capacity to soothe for weakness or naivety.
We may take the soother for a fool. We may
need soothing so much, we find ourselves unable
to ask for it nicely, shouting counter-productively
instead – or else we withdraw into defensive
independence, because help feels like it hasn’t
come soon enough. Those in the greatest need
of soothing often have no idea of what is
missing, no sensible way of articulating their
need – and a dogged suspicion of kindness
were it to be offered to them. We should strive
not to make things constantly scarier in our
own minds than they are in reality. We should
offer soothing continuously to others – and
insist to the more sceptical and parched parts
of our own minds that they too deserve one
day to be the beneficiaries of kindness
and reassurance.
Thank you for watching, remember to like the video and subscribe to our channel for more.
Our calm prompt cards can help us find serentiy despite daily anxieties and fustraitions.  To find out more click on the link now.